if you are present if you bring
Consciousness to Bear you are better at
every single thing you do you understand
that including relationships and
finances and every single thing is not
just sitting in a corner and trying to
enter some higher state of consciousness
bring your awareness of being into the
current moment and be present it sounds
good but to me those are just words and
it doesn't really come all the way home
so I'd like to start with an example
because we're not the first people to
use the word mindfulness let's say
you're driving when you are driving
there are traffic lights and I don't
know if you notice but they change
sometimes and it is really important
that you know that you get it all right
and and also in front of you there are
other drivers I hope you notice that and
they sometimes step under brakes and
these red lights come on in the back of
the car it's very important that you
notice that it's best that you be
mindful when you're driving when you go
to change lanes are you aware that even
if you look in your mirrors that there's
a thing called the blind spot you best
be mindful of that so if somebody's
teaching you how to drive they might use
that word be mindful of all times of
what's going on around you that is
mindfulness too all right and it is
exactly what we mean by being present in
the moment and bringing Consciousness to
Bear all right that's kind of neat isn't
it so you really do know about
mindfulness hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I make these videos because as a young
entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories motivation today so today let's
get some incredible motivation from the
one and only Michael a singer enjoy
what happens if you're driving and
you're not mindful
you crash
very very quickly all right aside from
the fact that there are lights there are
other cars there are blind spots there
are these things called Curves in the
road it best be that you know that
it's funny but do you understand what
I'm saying if you don't pay attention to
this if you are not present when you are
driving it will not take 10 seconds
before you crash do you understand that
you are not I mean forget about this you
know texting and so on right I'm just
talking about if you're not mindful
or sometimes I say to people let's say
you're driving and somebody cuts you off
all right which is really important when
we start talking about mindfulness it's
best that you notice it all right now
you're being asked to interact you're
being asked to be present and be present
enough to decide what to do what are
your actions
I will ask you is the is the amount of
mindfulness that you bring to your
driving going to affect the quality of
your driving how many tickets you get
how many accidents you get in and how
well you do let's say you're a Race Car
Driver
could you use the amount of mindfulness
that you bring to driving
for driving at Daytona at you know 180
200 miles an hour with 15 cars passing
you and the answer is no you better not
okay you best bring a lot more
mindfulness to the presence and what
that means as a race car driver right is
that hopefully there is nothing else
going on you're not thinking about the
fight you had with the wife you're not
worrying about this or that you had best
bring your Consciousness to bear in what
you are doing or you are in big trouble
all right but it's not just in driving
because I'm going to put that aside in
that particular case if you do not be
mindful you're in trouble not just as a
race car driver that's required more so
the more Prof then argue that the more
professional you get and the better you
want to do the more mindfulness you
better bring to bear is whether you're
talking about sports whether you're
talking about driving right the more
Consciousness you bring to bear I like
that term right I can use it because
we're using examples isn't that bringing
Consciousness to bear in the current
moment the more Consciousness you bring
to bear in the current current moment
the better you are what you're doing
anybody argue that right just take the
extremes don't bring any
okay let go of yourself
let go of yourself this thing you call
yourself your preferences your desires
your needs your bucket list and so on is
just a projection of the stuff you
stored inside but what do you mean if
you didn't have it you'd be filled with
love and filled with light you wouldn't
be asking any questions you'd love
having a child you'd love bring it up
you'd enjoy every moment of it if you
homeschool you don't homeschool it
doesn't make any difference everything
because you're fine and that's the
environment they grew up I was like grew
up in an environment where it's just
pure love and openness and understanding
as they have a problem they bring it to
you you don't say oh my God what did I
do what's it you just you have Clarity
you can share with them and help them
come to the solution themselves right
yeah so it's a healthy thing because
you're healthy so a parent shouldn't sit
there and say it's so hard to bring of a
child it's hard because you didn't bring
yourself up you didn't let go of your
own stuff right yeah so it's it's
there's so many things to learn yeah
it's all about you evolving as a being
as a being of light as a being of energy
and keep bringing yourself up and
letting go then you spread that light
everywhere that takes care of business
somebody wanted me to because I did
business I don't have business can you
give us spiritual talk on business right
I generally will say no I I don't want
to focus like like that right but the
truth is I would give the exact same
talk right how do you run a sales
business let go of yourself then you're
not making decisions based on your
garbage and your fears and past
experiences and all that kind of junk
you're bringing good energy into it and
it will attract good energy and people
around you will work with good energy
and they'll enjoy working with you yeah
my company we're technical high-tech
very few people ever left they loved
working there yeah right and I didn't
pay them the top salaries either because
we're out here in the middle of the
woods right and basically you just
create an environment for business an
environment for children environment for
love an environment for everything you
do that brings Beauty and love and
Clarity and selflessness true
selflessness into your environment it
will change everything this whole thing
about abundance and attracting to
yourself what it is that you want and
how to use mantras and spirituality to
make sure you have what you want true
spirituality is about not wanting true
spirituality is about being filled with
joy from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want is there a law of
attraction people ask me is there a law
of attraction yes and you better be
scared of it because if it's true that
you attract what your mind is thinking
you better take a look at what your mind
is thinking it's not only when you're
sitting there trying to attract
something to yourself with affirmation
what about your mind all day when it's
complaining and it's yelling at people
and it doesn't like stuff but if you're
attracting that way so you eventually
catch on that it is not about getting
what you want
it is about learning to find out that
what you really want is to stay open and
not have conditions on that openness and
then it comes down to how do you do that
are people capable of doing that or is
that just reserve for you know some
special beings Buddha and Christ that
have walked the face of the Earth
everybody is capable of that how do I
know that
if I tell you to pick up five thousand
pounds you may not be able to do that in
fact you won't you won't be able to do
that so I've told you to do something
that you have never done and you're not
doing it so you may not be able to do it
but if you're actually already doing
something
you're already doing it and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it so inside you are the one who's
closing your heart you close it you are
the one who's closing your mind you do
that they're your thoughts it's your
feelings they're nobody else's so you
are in there doing these things so if I
tell you the way to stay open is to not
close I don't teach how to stay open
that's more like finding out how to get
what you want I'm interested in you
learning to not close but a difference
if I say to you I want you to open your
heart right now you don't even know how
to start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only lasts a minute I'm
going to see a beautiful sunset you feel
like oh my God I looked in the face of
God then you go right back into your
mind with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want the teeth the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching you how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it mindfulness is
about this it is about finally waking up
one day and saying I'm the boss
of being here I have a mind
I can do better with it than letting it
be a horror show then letting it scare
me all the time then letting it remind
me of everything never bothered me then
letting it worry about what will happen
10 years from now or 20 years from now
that's not fun is it right if they say
you're going to give a talk in your
class all right A lot of people
the mind is a little trouble before that
doesn't it oh my God what if I forget my
lines what if I can't say oh I feel so
stupid I only want to do this does
anybody's mind ever do that to them
doesn't that help you perform better
no it doesn't
so I could just sit here for the whole
hour and a half and remind you of how
ridiculous it is what goes on inside
your head right it is worse than an arm
that won't stop doing this at least I
can paint all right and some people sit
there and say they want to sit there and
say but it's beneficial
to go over this stuff yes if something
happens to you and you make a mistake
sit down look at it pay attention learn
from it then for God's sakes not for the
next 20 years well they do that if I
hadn't done that this would have
happened do you understand that you
can't tell me there's a benefit there is
no benefit it's just that you haven't
learned
how to work with this thing called mine
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there basically there are three
categories or groups of objects of
Consciousness that your Consciousness is
aware of one is the outside world if you
close your eyes you don't see the
outside world if you open your eyes ah
there it is okay it comes in I discussed
in the book goes deep tries to be
somewhat scientific so that we fit into
an intellectual model because everything
is logical and and intellectual and
reasonable so the factor of the matter
is most people don't think about this
you don't really see through your eyes
your eyes are sensors we call them
senses but they're sensors if they
computer sensors that are picking up
light
turning it into signals that are being
sent up your nervous system you know
Optical nervous Optical nerves and then
it is rendering it inside your mind just
like you look at a flat scene scrap
excuse me a flat screen TV and you look
at it in there that's hard for us to
relate to because we're used our mind is
so intelligent that it creates 3D and
depth perception and everything even
though you're actually back in here
watching what's coming in and I like to
have fun with people I say I'll prove it
to you that it's really just light
that's bouncing off of objects and
coming into your eyes right turn off the
lights
and you won't see anything because then
there's no light bouncing off of things
that's how we think we think of drawth
life therefore I can't see no it's
because I turned off the light there's
no light bouncing off the objects and
coming reflecting back into your eyes
it's kind of neat isn't it all right so
it's it's fun to talk about this stuff
so one thing of the three new circus is
there's an outside world with all of its
objects and there's a lot of objects out
there the second is that's not all you
receive inside not all you're aware of
inside you're also aware of thoughts
which I'm sure we'll be talking about
deeper so just surface level it you're
aware of thoughts that go on in there
are you not right you you notice your
thoughts are talking to you notice you
can make your thoughts think different
things so you the Consciousness the
exact same Consciousness that is aware
of the outside world is aware of your
thoughts they're not separate not
categorizing it this is the
Consciousness here's my thoughts that's
the Consciousness this is the world you
can do them both at the same time
they're looking at something and
thinking about it and your same
conscience is the same both and then the
third is your emotions which are quite
different than thoughts and I'm sure
we'll talk more about that but basically
emotions or feelings their vibrations
that come up they're not thoughts or
thought forms you actually see a boat in
there you can see you know c words but
you can hear words they're talking to
you that voice inside your head emotions
are like that they're just basically
shift in energy patterns vibrations that
you pick up but they're very strong and
they catch your Consciousness so those
are the three things in the three things
Circus the outside world that you're
aware of the thoughts that are inside
your head your mind and the emotions
that emanate from your heart and the
Consciousness gets distracted by those
things that's so it's really funny that
the word distraction becomes a spiritual
word if you want to think of it that way
but deep spirituality deals with
distractions that's what it's all about
if you weren't distracted by your
emotions distracted by your thoughts or
distracted with the outside world you're
sitting in samadhi the Consciousness
would be able to come back into its
source when life strikes us and we feel
that internal reaction to the external
world it's still what's going on inside
how do we release that how do we let
that go so my experience is first of all
there are things you can do but the same
things everybody else teaches which is
don't hit somebody don't learn to shut
your mouth up you know let that Express
through your mouth because you're going
to pay for that right so the first thing
is a certain amount of self-control
which we all need in order to be
successful right but that's not the
answer yeah right the answer is every
single moment is not the big stuff that
you work with that's too late it already
bothered you it's you gotta yes you have
to deal with it yeah but what I want and
what I've learned is there is every
moment of your life little things that
create little irritations yes the
drivers driving 15 miles an hour below
the speed limit in front of you and
you're in a rush it rains when you have
to get out and deliver something it's
hot it et cetera et cetera right
somebody doesn't say hello hey Sally how
you doing she doesn't oh my God you will
watch your mind cause serious problems
all right so to me that is where the
growth comes from in those moments are
you willing to say come on what's the
cost benefit analysis of bothering
myself about the driver in front of me
it's not bothering them I guarantee you
they're not hearing a word you're saying
right so as a business person we're
supposed to take cost management
analysis maximum benefit for the least
cost those are 100 cost zero benefit
right or wrong it's all pain so you
don't do it so you learn and there are
lots of techniques you just learn to
work with yourself you can neutralize it
by saying something nice you can get a
mantra going inside so you pay attention
to something else instead of that or my
ultimate teaching and this year's also
in a sense is you relax
and you relax you just sit there and say
I can relax and breathe it's okay that
this is happening and then what you're
doing is allowing the energy to release
the whole idea is you don't engage with
it yes you sit behind it and you allow
it to release and not only do you go
through that moment okay now right but
you've actually let some of that stored
up stuff that's causing the problem like
what is road rage it's somebody who
because somebody beeped at them or is
driving slow has so much stuff inside of
them that it needs an excuse to come out
yeah that's it okay so we all I hope I
we I hope we don't know all right but we
all have stuff inside that we've stored
over our lives so by backing off and
letting go in these simple little
situations they matter it matters that
you're complaining about the heat yeah
you're saying that right It's Not
Innocent you're you're permitting
sometimes you get very angry about some
stupid thing you're giving a channel for
your stuff to come up and you're wired
yourself to complain exactly and so
instead you relax it's called r r you
get r r relax and release yes right and
what will happen is not only do you make
it past that moment without causing a
lot of trouble and taking on all kinds
of stuff but you've let some of that
stuff go and you get into the habit of
realizing hey I don't want that stuff
inside of me instead of asking why am I
not okay why I'm not okay you're asking
what do I need to be okay that's the
major difference of whether you're
growing inwardly or you're attached to
struggling externally is you think I can
only be okay if I get the things that I
got before
or similar you extrapolate right things
that made me had a relationship and
eighth grade and it was so beautiful and
she was redheaded okay my wife no that's
not true all right
he was redheaded and she left you know
so her parents move right and it was
never a bad experience in that
relationship it was just the most
perfect relationship you've ever had
right you understand now if I'm grown up
and I I go on a date and shoot a red hat
she redheaded I have a pretense
propensity toward being open you just
asked the question why do we think we
need these things all right because
we're not okay inside and we've had
experiences either you read a book it'll
tell you you need that to be okay you
watch a movie meet somebody you can have
a thought
if I had a Tesla
okay it used to be a Ferrari and I was a
Tesla all right I I had everyone would
be proud of me and I feel like I'm
helping the ecology and so all of a
sudden I'm not okay I'm going to go to
Tesla and if I get a Tesla oh my God for
a while how am I doing wonderful so
that's how you develop your preferences
is through programming you get
programmed by your past experiences what
do you really want
we talk about wisdom people talk about
attracting to themselves The Laws of
Attraction and all those sorts of things
but the question really is from a
spiritual point of view what do you
really want and religions about what
you're supposed to want and we know how
that works
spirituality is not about that
spirituality is about looking deeply
Within
and seeking truth Clarity that's what
it's about so this discussion is has
nothing to do with my feeling what you
should want or you even feeling guilty
or
weird about what you do want the
question is what do you really want
and the way to do that and I'm going to
be very bad in doing this is to say
here's a piece of paper not really but
figuratively and I want you to write
down what you want just take a little
time don't do it take a little time and
write down what you want and if you're
like most human beings probably first on
the list is a good relationship
something makes me feel important needed
wanted loved secure all that kind of
stuff and so whether you're in a
relationship I'd like it to get better
or someone so should behaves different
ways should understand me better
Etc or if you're not in a relationship
how to find my quote soul mate somebody
who just fits perfectly with me and
just fulfills the meaning of my life and
uh if we're really honest we write down
a nice house and a Ferrari or at least
some sort of a car and perhaps children
and or perhaps a little time without the
children and we make our list nobody's
judging just be honest you put that down
the purpose of this discussion is no
matter what you put on that list unless
you're very highly evolved
my experience is it's not really what
you want it's not that it's wrong it's
just not really what you want and the
way I prove that is as follows let's say
you put down I want a relationship I
want to meet somebody I want to have
that special relationship
and then I would ask you what if you
walked outside after this conversation
and all of a sudden there was this bush
in front of you and it started burning
like it did to Moses and talking to you
and its opening sentence was I am the
Lord your God
and I would like to discuss some things
with you
and said enough things that it knew
about you to where you were pretty
freaked out that you're actually talking
to an omniscient omniscient omnipotent
being or at least bush
and
the question that gets asked of you is
what would you like what do you want I
can grant whatever you want and having
gone through this exercise with me you
feel God thank God Mickey I'm prepared
this is neat I thought about it and you
say I want a relationship I want to meet
somebody I want to have that that thing
I've looked for my whole life or I want
a house or I want the perfect job I want
a job that makes me you know that
fulfills what I'm looking for
and with this bush what God tells you at
that point is I can give you that I have
the power to give you that but there's a
caveat which you probably want to hear
before I give it to you which is
I can give you that perfect person
they will be loyal to you they will stay
with you your entire life
but the caveat is
that you will be completely unfulfilled
you will feel sad every time you come
into the presence
you will not feel any love you will not
feel any joy happiness meaning but
they'll be there and they will dote all
over you and they will just be the most
perfect partner
that they could possibly be
or give you the job that you thought
would be the most amazing thing but it's
Hollow for you you go there and you
thought it would turn you on but it
doesn't
and you just Lowe's going to work and
you're just not excited about it
so therein lies there what do you really
want
because what you're going to find is if
you were given the opportunity to have a
relationship with that person I just
described or have the job I just
described but it didn't do SWOT for you
and it left you hollow inside you would
say I don't want it in fact if it's
going to make me miserable inside I
really don't want to keep it away from
me
and so to move quickly because we don't
have a little time here then I say you
lie to me when you said it was what you
really wanted
because it isn't true you wanted a
relationship it isn't true you want your
children it isn't truly wanted money it
isn't true you want to travel around the
world it isn't true that you want it et
cetera et cetera what's true is you
wanted to feel good inside
you wanted to feel love you want to feel
Joy you want to feel inspiration
excitement meaning those are inner
things there are outer things
you listed the things you listed
because you thought they would give you
what you really want
and so wisdom yoga spirituality
is about going deeper Buddhists talk
about working at the root so the truth
of the matter is the only thing you need
to write you needed to write on a piece
of paper when I asked you what do you
really want
is a sense of total well-being
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspiration I want to feel
meaning and depth train your mind not on
the site but when you're meditating when
you're driving but something train your
mind to say something over and over
again all right it can be a mantra it
can be the when people are into all that
stuff I tell them just say I can handle
this just train your mind to say I can
handle this I can handle this I can
handle this then when something takes
place that tries to pull your
Consciousness your awareness into that
negativity you'll find this is still
going on because it's a habit the mind
is full of habits isn't it you made a
good habit so now you have a choice put
your Consciousness on the noise or put
your Consciousness on the repetitive you
know the the Mantra the higher mind yeah
right and that works too so now that
you've moved your Consciousness instead
of having to change the mind right the
mind is free to release the whole idea
is releasing because when you let it
release it's releasing the stuff that
made it be like that yeah and all of a
sudden over time right you'll start to
be happier for no reason of course
there's a reason you're not carrying the
garbage inside of it yes and you've got
a new set of habits yeah
right but ultimately I always get in
it's relaxation yes ultimately you can
use all these techniques but when you
really are getting there you just relax
keep your hands off it's Judo yeah right
something attacked you let it go yeah
right there's a whole blade of grass
versus the oak tree yes a hurricane
can't rip off a great glass we can break
broken break an oak tree that's right
you just and that's what surrendered me
surrender does not mean not doing your
best at what you're doing and not being
competitive and giving up stuff it
doesn't mean that it means are you
willing to let go of your resistance yes
to what's going on outside and your
resistance to letting go of the thing
that's ruining your life which is the
stuff you stored inside what you want to
do is say what's behind the anxiety so
when when people talk I don't help
people make decisions but we talk about
decision making is the first thing that
matters is what's your motive
not what should you do if how can you
figure out what to do if you don't even
know your motive right and my you became
the spiritual teacher with every word
you said about this which is start from
the point of view do I want to get a
house or not
oh okay yes I like to have a house all
right can I afford a house don't worry
about what house what's your motive it's
very simple you know it's just I'm just
on to express myself and have a house
and and that's that and then stop there
don't say it has to be a certain way
when it's all said and done if you're
afraid of making the wrong decision who
defined it is wrong you well then don't
that's not what I was saying right if
you don't Define it as wrong I was a
builder okay you know before my personal
program before the program company I did
go with love my company I built this
house for this beautiful lady all right
who happened to be the manager of the
local bank and her name was Penny dollar
I swear to God her name was Penny dollar
right this is a long time ago back in
the 80s and basically she once came to
me and sat there and said I'm so scared
I said look I I'm gonna build a
beautiful house for you we've got it
everything's fine so I step in nights I
can't sleep what are you worried about
isn't it turning out nice I'm afraid
listen to this I'm afraid that I will
build the house and then I'll go to plug
in a lamp and the cord won't reach the
outlet
wow wow
thank you I said wow that's why they
make a stingy course
I was gonna say that's why they make
therapists but yes the challenges of
life are amazing what's wrong with
challenges we play sports we like
challenges nobody wants to play a team
that you beat 700 to 1 every time you
play them you want to be challenged you
want to have to bring out the best of
your being
if you can get clean inside where you're
not being run by all these past
Impressions we call them some scars in
yoga but all these past Impressions
which are telling you and they are
telling you constantly you can only be
happy if this happens and you can never
be happy if it doesn't and you will
never be happy if such and such happens
and then you go out into the world
chasing this
as opposed to working inside on yourself
to say I don't need those conditions
life is amazing I'm sitting on a planet
spitting in the middle of nowheres and
there's all these events happening don't
worry they won't last you're not going
to stay here but while you're here do
you want to run around and fight with
life and people and places and things
and even the weather to try to make it
be what you think you want
or do you want to work on yourself to
clean up this mess inside so you can be
open all the time that's what
spirituality is about it's not about
pronunciation it's pronunciation is too
late you've already decided that you
want something you need it to be happy
but you're not going to do it depth
spirituality is understanding you don't
need anything
you don't need anything doesn't mean you
don't do anything but you don't need
anything you're whole and complete
within yourself if you open there is
tremendous Joy love inspiration that
Wells up inside you the moment you open
the moment something happens that you
like watch how fast you feel Joy and if
something happens you don't like watch
how fast you close that is not teaching
you about the outside that's teaching
about the inside
that openness is where it's at closeness
is not openness is what you really want
because what does opening mean it's like
opening the blinds if you close the
blinds in your house your house is dark
it's like that chapter in the untethered
Soul take down the Walls if you close
the blinds in your house your house is
dark now you have to run around with
artificial light trying to figure out
how to get some light if you open the
blinds you don't have to do anything the
light is coming in but you won't open
the blinds until you're sure nobody's
out there and only the right people are
in your house and everything's exactly
what you want you're afraid to open the
binds you don't feel comfortable so you
either decide to spend your life trying
to build artificial light inside or you
decide to work on yourself so you want
to leave the blinds open yoga true
spirituality is about taking off the
blinds take them off the windowsill
throw them out and never ever close them
ever again what is the purpose of
closing it makes you sad it makes you
dark what is depression total darkness
total closeness you have closed off to
the flow of the energy there is no
reason for that there is no excuse for
that this is your world inside it's your
mind it's your heart it is your
responsibility to not close it how dare
you think you're going to meet somebody
who will overcome your tendency to close
I want a job don't give me that job
you're going to know your whole life
building all these Impressions that
bother you or scare you and turn you on
and then you say to me as a relationship
that it's my responsibility to keep your
mind open and your heart open when
you're in there closing it all the time
I hope that seems silly and
counterproductive it is your
responsibility to keep your mind open it
is your responsibility to keep your
heart open and once you learn to do that
they're your mind and your heart once
you learn to do that you will feel Joy
all the time and I mean all the time
from the moment you wake up in the
morning you'll be inspired you'll love
to go to work even if you went to the
same job for 30 years you don't ever get
bored why because just energy flowing up
inside of you you will get the most out
of your relationships you'll be able to
give the most to all moments that are
fully in front of you why because now
you're a giver instead of a taker when
we come into the moment into interaction
with the moments in front of us we're
looking to see what we can get we're
looking to see how we want them to be
we're speaking to change things we're
dressing certain ways we're doing all
kinds of things to manipulate the
moments so that they will be the way we
want and when they come inside they'll
turn us on a being who has learned to be
open all the time never does that they
don't need to do that because they're
already feeling what they want to feel
they're feeling Joy they're feeling love
they're feeling inspiration
so now when the momentum Falls in front
of them they can give to it they can
take this joy and love that they have
and they can then shine it upon the
moment people place them things that are
unfolding so this is spirituality
there's always a voice in my mind oh I'm
crazy like I'm doing something that's
wrong I'm going to be a gigantic failure
like you know people would look at your
laugh at you and all that but I think
those voices are I mean you talked about
actually in all three books about the
preferences and things you like how our
mind works
um I think it's pretty common yeah have
you had those voices and how do you deal
with this voice well and I explained in
the beginning of the surrender
experiment yeah that's how I started my
spiritual journey is I was sitting on a
couch with a friend of mine back in who
knows 69 70 maybe and uh there was a
lull in the conversation and
somehow that's not comfortable even with
friends you know that you were talking
and then there's nothing to say and you
try to think of things to say to keep
keep the conversation go the
conversation feeling comfortable yeah
it's really about control because you
have a certain amount of control that
you know this person is interacting with
you they're okay yeah you know what I'm
talking about all right yeah and so I
noticed that that was going on inside my
head that he was anxious even with a
friend all right that there was this
sense of discomfort in the silence yeah
and Mickey Michael was trying to think
what to say to this day it was 52 years
ago I remember the whole exact moment or
where it is and he's sitting there
saying oh it's kind of hot out isn't it
or would you like to get something to
eat maybe we get a pizza Jesse he kept
saying these things yeah and inside I
noticed that that's going on in my mind
they all seem very stupid to say and I
didn't save them for the first time in
my life I didn't go along with that was
what the mind was saying and then I
realized uh who am I that is noticing
the mind saying that and as simple and
silly that seems that guided the rest of
my life period that moment woke me up to
realize wait a minute it's always
talking
right as I was trying to figure out
whether to eat or something it's always
saying something it's busy judging and
thinking and liking and not liking and
figuring out what to do yeah but now I'm
not it I'm watching it do that yeah
right Awakening to witness Consciousness
but I had no background I never met
anybody yeah
nothing yeah nothing yeah it just
happened okay and I'm watching it and I
started to feel I don't want to be that
I don't want to be like that yeah right
yeah and so I remember the first thing I
said instead of do you want to do this
should we do this so I'm watching this
voice inside my head telling me what to
say but I'm feeling distant from it for
the first time in my life and so instead
of saying well I finally talked I didn't
say where do you want to go what do you
want to do isn't it hot you know do you
remember what Nixon did the other day or
something I sat there and said I have
this voice inside of my head talking do
you have one and as I said to him and he
was a famous lawyer he was my
brother-in-law at the time and he was a
big lawyer in Chicago and they never
thought about these kind of things and
basically he looked at me and he looked
at me strange was this kind of look and
all of a sudden bam this light went on
in his eyes it was so beautiful a light
when I said yeah I know just what you're
talking about my my never shuts up and
there it was that was and the rest of
all my years I mean it stops so I don't
have to work with as much but everything
was about that voice yeah right so
you're talking about how yours was
telling you you can't do this my whole
thing from that moment forward was wait
a minute I don't need this chunk going
inside my head yeah it's so distracting
it's so negative it tends to be negative
right and so on so by the time I was
building the house I had started to work
with that voice and this I started
working with a town just shut up I said
shut up shut up I don't want to talk to
you
you realize that's the voice telling the
voice to shut up yeah it took it took
quite a while for me to wake up to
realize how to work with that right but
at that time I was not listening to it
if it said you can't build that house I
said sure shut up
which is not the right way do not do
that the president that is not the right
way to deal with that voice in your head
all right but so it wasn't a problem
because I wasn't listening to it yeah so
I was just letting this unfold as it was
happening yeah and putting my whole
heart and soul into this is what I need
to do to get to where I want to go right
so I'm going to do it yeah there's no
complaining know this know that yeah so
that's the answer how important is the
slowing down or the relaxation I think
of relaxation I for me I think I've got
to slow it down when it slows down it
doesn't have the bite it doesn't have
the power I'm able to become the witness
how do you slow it down and is that an
important part of it or not in your
experience I don't any longer have to
slow it down it's it's like learning to
walk because I learned to ride a bike
it doesn't take your different stages
right so first and in the book there's a
chapter called Oprah said it was her
favorite chapter it's called let go now
or fall yes the moment is very much what
you were telling the moment you see like
anger doesn't happen all at once it
starts like it starts down there that's
when you have to deal with it yeah
sincere enough to say I don't even want
to know what I'm about to get angry
about yes I know that that's not a part
of my being I need to listen to All
right so when it starts you relax right
it's that commitment to relax your relax
your shoulders relax your chest relax
your tummy it doesn't take time there's
nothing there's nothing you have to put
aside time to do this right you just
have to be conscious be committed right
so you relax it and you lean away you
just lean away from the noise right and
you actually don't realize that at first
it feels good because you didn't get
angry you did get all involved or
neurotic or whatever it was right and
react but you're actually leaning into a
deeper part of your being when you lean
away from the lower part of your being
right and I want to do one little thing
because a lot of your people are very
successful obviously they work with you
so they get successful right and I often
have people say to me I don't want to
give up the fear I don't want to give
the anger it's what drives me it's what
I use come on yeah you know they say
that yeah it's what I use to be
successful right if I give that up why
would I get out of bed in the morning
they actually ask that right and what
what you're missing is for one thing
there are lots of things you can use
drugs all kinds of things please don't
all right that temporarily or
momentarily can give you some energy
right but they will destroy you anger
will destroy you fear will destroy you
they burn out your adrenals they burn
out your system so it's not a long-term
solution and this question of if I don't
have that to drive me why would anything
drive me right have you ever fallen in
love
who's ever fallen in love do you find
that you're driven to be with the person
do you find you want to get things for
him or her do you find right yes love is
a motivator way greater than fear or or
anxiety or or any of that kind of pain
you know the anger love motivates you to
give and express itself love wants to
express itself so what happens is when
you let go of this lower stuff you'll
start noticing love starts to come up
you're starting to open up to the higher
energies yeah one opportunity that
always presents itself constantly in a
workplace
is perfecting your interaction with
other people
it's a relationship just like your
personal relationships that you have at
home you have relationships with every
single person you're interacting with
and we need to learn to perfect those
and by perfecting those we'll perfect
ourselves why what happens naturally as
we've discussed earlier is we've had
experience in our lives
those experiences have carved you
they've carved your sense of good and
bad and and what you like and what you
don't like what you're afraid of and
what you desire Etc these are not things
you decided they are things that your
environment and your experiences left
these Impressions these Impressions got
left on top of you so now what happens
is when you look out into the world what
you see is yourself you know that you've
all heard that before so you look
outside because you're looking through
the glasses of your own personal
experiences everything looks that way
well that's not a good foundation for
working with other people and what
you're going to find out is that you
become very critical of other people so
if you're a boss when you look at other
people you think that your employees
they should be doing things the way you
thought the way you do them so what it
comes down to is how do I use my
interaction with the people in my
Workforce in my workplace to perfect
myself so that I learn how to get along
with people that are different than me
the beauty of when you go home there's a
handful of people you know one two three
your family when you go to the workplace
there's lots of people and so you get
this tremendous opportunity
to learn how to work with diversity
people are diverse
so how do I go about working with people
first you start by neutralizing yourself
you realize that your view of how it
should be done what everything is is
just your view so you try to listen say
what other people are trying to say
through their actions about how they
would go about doing it now I could give
you a nice talk about how everybody has
contribution ever has something to give
and just give them an opportunity let's
say you're past that and what you see is
that things are not being done in a way
that is constructive or ultimately
constructive or ultimately efficient
you're the boss you're somebody in a
position that's your responsibility to
get things running as good as possible
is even as smooth and effective as
possible efficient as possible so how do
I deal now with a person who's going
about their business and it's not coming
out that way I look at it as an
opportunity to perfect the universe it
is not something against the other
person I'm not criticizing the other
person even Within Myself they're not
doing anything wrong the universe
created them they are the result of
everything that caused them to be the
way they are everything's that way and
I've now been put in a position where I
can help to raise the universe to help
it run more smoothly help it run better
so you start off with a constructive
view that if something is not perfect in
front of you that's a good thing that's
an opportunity for you it doesn't get
you upset it doesn't make you frustrated
it doesn't make you angry therefore when
you approach the other person you're not
putting them on a defensive point of
view if you cause defensiveness in
another person you've not done your job
because nobody does good based on
defensive or fear that is not a
foundation for good work so basically
you approach it from the point of view
of that person is me and I have these
blockages I have this inability to see
something how do I work with myself how
do I change this and a lot of times
you'll end up working with a person not
even about the thing that you want to
talk about you start working at another
level with the person and help them work
through what issues they have that are
causing them to be the way they are and
it becomes a friendship it becomes a
beautiful experience you find that your
entire interaction with every single
person in your life is giving you are
serving that's all you're doing it is
your job to help it be the best that it
can be they're not serving you I'm CEO
of accompanied all these people not
serving me I'm here to serve them I'm
here to help them be better once you get
comfortable be in with reality this is
very deep this is what loud Sue tried to
talk about in the doubt now that you are
willing to let go of yourself your
personal self and interact with reality
your awareness is now experiencing
reality you will find that there's not
one single moment that unfolds in front
of you that is not calling to you to
interact with it it is there you are
there because you are meant to be with
each other that's how perfect it is it's
like the most perfect relationship
people looking for their soul mates it's
right in front of you it's called life
it is the most perfect fit for your
being that's why you're there and it's
there and you will feel it and you will
know what to do I'm telling you you will
never ever have trouble making a
decision again for the rest of your life
you will never wonder you will never
have any angst or anything it'll just be
the universe it's sort of like listen to
me you're on the ocean on a surfboard
how do you know when to go up and when
to go down you don't the wave does it
for you you just ride the wave the wave
comes up you go up the wave goes down
you go down but what if I want to go
down when it goes up you fall what if I
want to go up when it goes down you fall
it's like you just interjected yourself
into a system that you're supposed to be
in harmony with and if you are in
harmony with it you will know exactly
what to do because it's telling you what
to do is that telling you with words but
it is telling you what to do isn't it
it's telling you what to do it's a go to
the right go to the left feel it be in
harmony with it that's how you ride a
wave that is the Dao that is what
lautson was talking about how you ride
life if you're not busy in there wanting
it to be other than it is then you are
in harmony with what it is the moments
know where there going they're part of a
Harmony that's moving through time and
space you are here to experience that
and participate in that you don't have
to do anything it is happening to you
you're happening with it and then you're
going to see that what happens you start
just being with it and everyone looks at
you and says oh you're so good at
everything you do you're not doing
anything you're not doing a single thing
but you're neither doing nor not doing
that's the deepest of all the teachings
you are there with it it's doing
something the ocean is doing something
so obviously if you're on the ocean and
the ocean's doing something it looks
like you're doing something seriously
what I just told you is the entire
bhagavad-gita it's the deepest teaching
you will ever even come close to
everyone will think you're doing things
you're not doing a single thing but
you're also not not doing either right
you are just being on the ocean and
being with it and the ocean knows where
it's going therefore you will be the one
who's in harmony with everything it's so
simple that we miss it if you want to
play baseball and you want to pick up a
grounder I do not think that what you
should be doing is is guessing where
it's going to go next you should be
watching it why because it knows where
it's going next you see that scenes are
weird you're the smart one you should be
the one who can figure it out I
guarantee you right now that ball knows
more about where it's going than you do
the ground and the ball and the
interacting with them knows way more
about what's going to happen next than
anything you're going to figure out
that's why they say keep your eye on the
ball they don't say keep your eye on
your mind they don't say that they say
keep your eye on the ball in every sport
why because the ball knows where it's
going it just it's the forces of nature
therefore it knows where it's going it
is perfectly in harmony with all the
forces that it's interacting with isn't
it so if you keep your eye on the ball
you have a better chance of being where
it's going because you're paying
attention to where it's going you're not
guessing you're not figuring you're not
using logic you're not worrying you're
not angsting you're not hoping you're
not praying even a good religious coach
if you say coach when the ball is hit
should I close my eyes and pray that I
get it or should I watch the ball
they're gonna tell you to forget the
praying stuff at that time pray that you
can keep your eye on the ball all right
you're supposed to keep your eye on the
ball and it's the same thing with life
I'm telling you it's exactly the same
you come into harmony with the moments
that are unfolding in front of you well
why would I do that I'm not even gonna
answer you if you're sat here this long
because they are the moments who are
sitting in front of people what if I
don't like them it has nothing to do
with like and dislike does it it has to
do with Dancing with it what I don't
like what the waves are doing then don't
surf because you're going to fall and
it's the same way with life I'm here for
a little while on the planet Earth just
a very little time a few years and I get
to see I don't get to see much it's
really embarrassing I only get to see a
little tiny bit that's in front of me
and I get a moment I miss everything
else you understand that those of you
think you know something you don't know
anything
here's a book it's just the most
brilliant book read one word give me the
book back
do you know the book
here's a moment in life there are 700
billion quillion going on at the same
time you saw one you know what's going
on
no you don't know what's going on you
know the slightest idea was going on you
only know what you picked up so I told
you statistically what you picked up is
statistically insignificant
in fact it rounds to zero point oh oh am
I right or wrong you see it so therefore
what you picked up can't be anything
it's nothing it's zero
but you think it's everything and to you
it is everything because it's the only
thing you picked up your Universal set
is like nothing is just God I'm trying
to talk to you intelligently
so the right way to come into the moment
is to sit here and realize I'm a
conscious being that's a blessing
however it came from I don't know but
I'm here I know I'm here and I'm
conscious and there's this moment of
folding in front of me I am well aware
that there are 700 billion zillion going
on everywhere that I'm not experiencing
but I can't do anything about that let
me at least experience the one I'm
experiencing wow it's kind of neat let
me at least experience what I'm
experiencing like a gift this is the
gift that's being given to you there's
another gift being given to everybody
else there's seven billion people on the
planet Earth every single one of them
experience something different every
single moment
that's what they're experiencing that's
the gift that's being given to them and
so you actually come into the moment I'm
afraid to say it with a sense of Honor
with a sense of respect with a sense of
gratitude you sit there and say to the
moment wow thank you this is the one I
got to experience has nothing to do with
what I want what I don't want what
should be or what shouldn't be it has to
do with my humility of realizing I am
not the creator of the universe I am the
experiencer of this moment that's what I
am there are forces that are creating
the universe you do know that you want
to call them science I love you want to
call it God I love it makes no
difference just call it not me
that's the nicest name for the creator
of the universe not me because you know
it's not you don't you okay you just
gotta sitting here picking up the moment
that's in front of you then honor and
respect that experience you start by
honoring respecting and accepting the
blessing and the reality and the right
of what is unfolding in front of you if
you don't like it you look at that it's
disharmonious you let go of yourself and
that's Christ said you must die to be
Reborns we're talking about you
literally do the process don't get mad
at yourself for being a certain way just
don't participate in that part of your
being you don't have to get mad at your
hand because it wants to pick up a
cigarette just don't pick up the
cigarette in fact if you get mad at your
hand you'll probably be so stressful you
will pick up the cigarette then you
definitely need a cigarette and say they
were drinking just don't do it don't get
mad don't do anything just don't
participate in the process that will not
take you where you want to go so if you
find yourself make up an alternate
reality I am begging you to just let it
go if you find yourself not liking the
reality it's unfolding in front of you I
am begging you relax and let go all
right that's not the end of your
relationship with life that's the
beginning of your relationship with life
your mind is a very great thing it is
brilliant it took medals and sand and
taught the sand to think and silicon and
took metals and made a rocket ship got
inside and flew to the moon
oh my God you are brilliant I have a
brilliant mind okay that's not the
problem the problem is what you're doing
with it when you go to that brilliant
mind you say I'm not okay because I
store all this junk inside of me figure
out how everybody else needs to be so I
can be okay
there's a total misuse of mine stop it
that's what you do that's your Technique
stop doing that don't use your mind for
that that's the personal mind don't use
your mind for that use your mind for
great things don't use your mind for
sick things but then what do I do about
the fact that I'm not okay fix it
I'll make everybody
happy different so you can be okay don't
have all these rules of how everything
needs to be so you feel better find out
why you're not okay how's that who'd it
say work at the root that's the root
right well why am I not okay I told you
you just weren't listening you're not
okay because you shoved all this stuff
inside of you of every single experience
you ever had in your life that bothered
you they weren't comfortable with
they're going to be things that are
uncomfortable you see a rattlesnake all
coiled up rattling oh that's not
comfortable I promise I've seen him all
right it's it's supposed to scare you
you gotta straight that's why he's doing
it it's not wrong it's not bad it didn't
ruin your life it's a heck of an
experience in fact does that mean I
should go pick it up no you respect the
experience you're having and then you
let it pass
you're a greater being
[Music]
experience I don't know how to explain
that to you why do you practice tennis
why why do you when you practice tennis
you just have the ball you know the ball
server the brought up my server you just
have it come exactly where your strength
is every single time so you can get
better at where you're strong no you hit
it all over the place why because every
single angle you get better because you
use those muscles and because you came
in tune right or wrong practice makes
perfect well if practice makes perfect
in sports why does practice not make
perfect in life
experience is your best teacher
therefore every single experience you
have you have it and it passes through
you don't hold on to the rattlesnake so
that you miss the next experiences honor
and respect the experiences you had
everyone the divorce to this the
children traumas I don't care I'm
serious stop it you're not a victim
you're someone who received the gift of
experience how's that the fact that it
wasn't comfortable with the rattlesnake
wasn't comfortable fine that's part of
the experience Let It Go I'm glad I had
that experience now I know better about
rattlesnakes I met one okay
um I know how to deal with it well okay
fine you've met divorce your parents got
divorced wonderful you win the person
whose parents didn't get divorced they
lost they didn't get to have that
experience that's how you have to look
at it every single experience you have
is it's weight in gold it's a gift from
God and it's your gift because nobody
else had your experience so you process
these let them go that's your spiritual
path if meditation helps meditate Mantra
helps do Mantra but the purpose is not
meditation or Mantra or any other
techniques the purpose is are you
willing to stop storing inside of you
the things that were difficult when you
had the experience because otherwise you
store difficulty inside of you it's
going to be there all the time you
understand that you have a bad smell
don't collect them and take them home so
you put them in a room and remember how
bad it was and how much you didn't like
it just let it pass open the windows or
don't I don't know what to do when I get
a scrum kind you always forget but just
let it go and it'll be over
yes don't ever drive down that road
again don't you hear me let your
experiences pass and they will have fed
you you'll become a whole person because
you had them you don't need to hold them
in your mind that is spirituality and
now I showed you why spirituality and
life are the same thing aren't they
that's the highest way to live your life
that's the highest way to become
spiritual so find a way to work with
yourself inside instead of trying to use
your mind to avoid yourself don't let
your mind say how you want things to be
or not it's so foreign to people don't
oh I want things to be the way they are
and what I want is to be able to honor
and respect the reality of the moment in
front of me that's the last want that
gets left that's your work and you work
on that one it's over isn't it so little
by little
work with the things that are unfolding
in front of you don't store them honor
them respect them let them pass and
because you're not putting more stuff
down then the old stuff will come up by
itself I promise you don't worry it will
you'll come complain the old stuff will
start coming up Let It Go
Let It Go you do not want any of it in
you let it go if it needs to come up Let
it welcome it sing hey come on up you're
welcome here kiss it throw a party
really tell you the worst stuff you have
in there welcome it up just relax and
release as it comes up and it'll go
it'll pass not all at once it'll pass
and where do you see I'm telling you
your energy will come free inside you'll
wake up in the morning with ecstasy
pouring with your being that worries
about what happened
and then all through the day it feeds
you it rises up inside of you feeding
you all the time that's what your life's
supposed to be like Karma Yoga is about
everything else
that's why Karma Yoga is the deepest
yoga it's not about your relationship
with your body with your heart with your
mind or even with your higher bodies
it's about your relationship with the
rest of the world with the rest of
what's unfolding in front of you how do
I interact with the reality of life that
keeps manifesting before me that is the
topic of Karma Yoga and it's often
considered the deepest yoga because it
is so expansive in one's life in fact
one of the deepest spiritual scriptures
in yoga the bhagavad-gita is considered
A Treatise on Karma Yoga
so what is karma yoga what is our
relationship with the world around us
in order to understand that to begin to
truly understand that you have to
understand two things one who are you
who's in there looking out what is the
nature of your being that has a
relationship with the world around you
and the second is what is the nature of
the world outside of you
first is actually quite simple
you are the one who's in there looking
out
this is what the essence of witness
Consciousness and Krishna murder used to
talk about objective observation
you are the indwelling being who looks
out through your eyes hears through your
ears you are the one who knows you have
a body you are the one that was in there
when you were six years old and when you
looked in the mirror you saw a
six-year-old's body now you see whatever
age you are and it will continue on you
are the Consciousness the awareness of
being you see the emotions that are
coming up from your heart you see the
thoughts that are created in your mind
and ultimately you experience great love
and sometimes Bliss as you get deeper
within yourself it's all the same you
there's just one of you there that's you
well what is the nature or the reality
of the world outside of you that is one
of the most fascinating and beautiful
topics
if you turn to science they will tell
you that 13.8 billion years ago there
was this big bang
and subsequent to that there were these
thick gases of hydrogen and helium
that fuse together based on gravity and
built the universe as you know it
a wise person realizes that every single
moment of their life
what is unfolding in front of them is
the result of 13.8 billion years of the
universe unfolding and evolving until it
finally landed at their doorstep and
presented the moment that's in front of
them
to them so the world outside of you is
not of your own making
the world outside of you belongs to
science belongs to God it belongs to
Evolution it belongs to cause and effect
it is indeed the moment in front of you
took 13.8 billion years to get there you
can't call it your own you didn't make
it you weren't even here
the other way to know that the world
outside of you has absolutely nothing to
do with you it belongs to itself is to
realize that the moment in front of you
is no different than the moment to your
left or the moment to your right or the
moment behind you or the moment anywhere
else in the universe the universe is
expressing itself
everywhere you're just seeing one
particular moment one particular point
you can't say that because it's the part
that you see there's something special
about it it's just the part that you see
so a wise person comes to the point of
realizing that they are inside looking
out what is outside is the result of
creation it is not theirs it doesn't
belong to them it is just passing by and
they just happen to be seeing that
moment so karma yoga raises the Deep
question what then is my relationship to
the world that's unfolding in front of
me if it doesn't belong to me and it
doesn't again let's spend one more
moment with that if I picked you up out
of the moment you're in and dropped you
onto a street in Paris
then that would be the moment you see
obviously that moment was there before
you got there and if I take you away the
moment will be there after you leave it
has absolutely nothing to do with you
eventually a wise person realizes that
it's true of every moment if I walk in a
restaurant
that restaurant existed before I got
there it was going on the people were
there conversations were going on music
was going on whatever food was going on
I then step in I'm just seeing a moment
that already exists when I step out the
moment will keep going on it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to itself
belongs to science belongs to God
it's such a beautiful thing to see that
the world outside of you exists
independent of you you are experiencing
one particular moment of it the world
has its ebb and flows it has its cycle
and it should have its cycle and you do
not understand those cycles and you will
never understand those Cycles how could
you possibly do you only see this tiny
bit of life it's a hole its Cycles are
in harmony with its Universal self you
only see the way when it passes by you
say oh I shouldn't be doing that why
because it messed up my face and her
reflection that's why you'll always do
it in relationship to you you want to
know how wrong you are every single time
you say something's good or bad or right
or wrong or better or worse or preferred
or not preferred I'm going to ask you
based on what every one of those things
are relative term good bad right wrong
preferred not preferred those are
relative terms she doesn't agree she
doesn't agree everyone's got their own
thing don't they they're relative and
I'm going to ask you based on what and
if you're honest you're gonna say based
on Me based on my view of the world
based on my value system so what who
cares about your value system there's
narcissus again there you are looking
into the universe and seeing the
reflection of yourself and saying that's
what matters so it's you just get to the
point where you stop putting so much
weight on yourself stop being narcissist
your face is just one of 700 billion
things in the universe your spiritual
journey is about ceasing to think that
you matter it is about ceasing to think
that you are the center of your Universe
the universe is the center of the
universe it's about Lake not about face
it just keeps coming back to the same
thing you have to wake up to that so
your spiritual growth is not about
getting into yourself or changing your
views or duh you need to go in there and
mess around with your mind is crazy your
mind doesn't matter it's a nothing you
know how long it takes to erase a hard
disk just take a good magnet pass it
across it's gone so it's just
meaningless what you have in there stop
rearranging the darn thing what matters
is life itself God the universal get to
know her how by ceasing seem to be so
interested in yourself so when you look
into the lake of life and that's what
you're doing every minute of every day
you understand that you're looking into
the lake of life when you look into the
lake of life will you please stop seeing
yourself there's lots and lots and lots
of things out there stop seeing yourself
how do I know that I'm seeing myself I
will give you the biggest clue It Ever
Was it offends you you feel a change in
the force in the energy in the Shakti
flow sometimes you do don't you like
lots of times if you look out into this
Lake of life and it causes a change in
the flow of the chi inside of you you
have projected yourself into life and it
hit your projection I want this to
happen I want that to happen the cause
of suffering is desires Buddha it's all
the same teaching you are projecting
from inside out therefore the innocence
of life is hitting your projections
causing you to suffer causing change to
happen inside your piece it's disturbing
the peace you want to stop that you want
to find true spirituality you have to
let go of projecting yourself to life
what is love Shakti the energy rising up
to the fourth chakra and pouring out the
floor chakra that's what you would call
love and to cut the tuning with somebody
who you like if if they talk the way you
want to dress the way you want act the
way you want etc etc you open and then
the energy can come up and you feel this
experience of love but what if you're
not closed what if you never close
this is all love you know it should take
for you to feel love anytime you want
just wave your hand in front of your
heart and Bliss pours for your heart all
the time anytime you want that is what
it means to reach a state of Happiness a
state of pure unconditional happiness
it's inside of you it's available to you
I would love to feel that
what we talk about today and what you
end up doing with it can help you be the
best of whatever you chose to be because
we're talking about it's your choice
which you choose to be all right and you
have a lifetime to do it but there are
things that can help you be that and one
of those like I said the most simple
level is you take decent care of your
body if you don't take decent care of
your body it doesn't do well does it and
when it's not doing well you can't do
well you can't go to work you can't
concentrate and so on
I want to talk about what mindfulness
really is it gets pigeonholed into
different things it really is about
saying can we have a discussion about
what you're doing with your mind there
that's mindfulness
be mindful of what you're doing with
your mind so what does that mean you
raise your hand you say to me well I use
my mind to study I say wonderful great I
hope you do well at it I use my mind to
do research I'm into research wonderful
that's a great thing to do with your
mind I use your mind I love to read and
learn about history and whatever it is
that you're doing with your mind be
mindful of what your mind is doing or
you're going to be in big trouble
what is your mind doing it's really very
very easy I guarantee you it takes you
10 seconds you won't like what you see
what you're going to see is that when
you are not using your mind when am I
not using your mind when you're driving
down the road going somewhere when
you're sitting on the potty whatever you
want to call it right all the moments
you take in your life where you are not
consciously doing something I guarantee
you there's something going on in your
mind what's it doing oh my God I can't
believe I said that I am so embarrassed
that was ridiculous if I hadn't said
that I was doing this anybody's mind do
that answer me okay what is the benefit
of that
the answer is zero do you understand
that how about this you're driving down
the road you're going on a vacation or
driving to Miami and there's a sign a
billboard on the road and it reminds you
of a relationship that your problem you
had with your father or your mother 25
years ago and your mind starts
reiterating the discussion as if it was
going on now or your ex-husband or
whatever it is and it's still going on
in there isn't it what in the world is
that of what benefit is that very few of
you in business in relationships in life
would allow a cost-benefit analysis take
place of which the cost is 100 and the
benefit is zero and you would still do
it
correct that's what I'm telling you that
is the cost is a hundred percent and the
benefit is absolutely zero all it does
is cause you trouble it makes you
neurotic it makes you nervous it makes
you scared do you understand that so why
are you tolerating that that's what
mindfulness is about we Define a world
inside ourselves that supports our
self-concept and we need that because
we're hiding from ourselves behind the
self-concept right and because we Define
the world that way we neither all to be
that way right but the world has nothing
to do with what we made up the world is
what it is it's reality it's it's
beating to a whole different realm it's
beating to science it's beating like hey
then our rain today it's my birthday
that's stupid dumb what are you doing in
the rain has nothing with your birthday
has to do with meteorology and low
pressure zones right so you've now left
yourself vulnerable to the unfolding of
reality is going to destroy you right
so that's what you were saying and
that's absolutely true so even if I sit
down and I write my list
to begin the day
and then I follow that list in order to
basically make myself feel less insecure
the truth is I'm more vulnerable yes
because things may interrupt that list
that I don't have control over and then
I will be sort of subject to that
experience
if you're living your life to hide from
yourself
you're not going to get anywhere
it starts you ask me how do you do this
it starts when you say I don't know what
that anymore
I don't want my state of being to be
completely dependent upon somebody
else's mood upon how somebody else does
or doesn't do or
et cetera et cetera Etc up in the
unfolding of the weather or the unfully
of the world right I want to find my
true being I want to find me in here and
be okay then I'll come into the world
it's not that you don't come in the
world let me come into the world and be
motivated by love be motivated by
compassion be motivated by creativity by
inspiration instead of be motivated by
fear which is what we are motivated by
right okay it's like the most powerful
of us try to stay really powerful
because the thought of I mean some of
these very powerful people the minute
they're out of office or out of this or
finances go wrong they're jumping off
buildings
right or wrong right it happened didn't
it right okay that's because they were
not powerful
they were supported by something because
they were needing and that it was weak
and that strength came from conditional
like a conditional State the moment that
conditional State went away well it's
over I don't want to face this why would
meditation work with meditation got to
do with me who's in here and struggling
with myself
meditation is very very simple in the
simplest sense
the simplest meditation nowadays that's
taught is 15 minutes in the morning 15
at night sit down and watch your breath
go in and out well what's so holy about
watching your breath go in and out
what's that got to do with yoga
if you are watching your breath go in
and out you are not watching your mind
complain about what's going on
you're not letting your mind you're not
watching the mind that is participating
in the game of what do I want what do I
not want and how do I make it happen you
are instead focusing your awareness on
the breath going in and out believe it
or not that will completely change your
life why for the very reason that you're
not participating in the Disturbed mind
the mind will always be disturbed if the
foundation of the mind is what do I want
what do I not want and how do I make it
happen
that is very disturbing because you have
pitted yourself against the unfolding of
reality in front of you if you watch
your breath go in and out or any other
technique of meditation you use whatever
is comfortable to you works for you if
you're watching your breath go in and
out you are not watching your mind live
your life decide what should be
happening and getting upset or excited
about it that very Act of not watching
the Disturbed mind permits you you in
there the one that I said are you in
there hi
you're in there but you're watching your
mind all the time and participating in
the mind's attempt to make things be the
way it wants every single moment is an
exciting challenge to do your best to
bring your A game to everything that's
going on right it's like sports I
shouldn't talk about it now but anyways
you know sometimes we win something so
we lose the question is did you enjoy
the game did you get better because of
it if you played a competitor that was
better than you that's wonderful you
learned you understand that it's the
same thing with relationships if you're
in a relationship and it didn't work out
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that did you learn did you grow are you
better now to move on with your life
every single moment of life is a
learning experience do you understand
that the point that I see I get across
to people I say to you you are always
better oh I'm in trouble and I'll step
back you are always better off having
had an experience than not having had it
you are a holder person because you had
an experience do you understand that if
you didn't ever travel somewhere then
you didn't have an experience if you
didn't ever fall in love you don't know
anything about it you're a novice you're
nothing right you are when you have an
experience when life gives you the gift
of an experience and you experience it
and you learn from it how can you tell
me you're not better off than you were
before you had the experience it can't
make you worse off unless you resist the
experience
then it can really make you worse off
candidate if you don't like the
experience and you resist it it can ruin
your life but the fact that you got to
have the experience is really special
it's a special thing it's a thank you
this gives you a taste of how a mindful
person lives but you can't just decide
to live like that because then you're
going to suppress the issues you have
inside right you're going to come to me
and say but what if somebody dies but
what do I do if this happens right you
didn't catch on yet right get yourself
together be happy inside be whole Feel
Complete right Feel Love pouring up
inside of you because you don't have
this junk stored inside of you then go
out and bring that into this world with
enthusiasm with passion with love right
and interact with every single thing
that life brings before you with a sense
of honor and respect and gratitude for
the right to be able to do that you have
the right to live like that if you're a
student love going to school don't go to
schools they can graduate and then go
get a job in there and say what are you
crazy school is one of the need
especially College that's got to be one
of the neatest experience you'll ever
have in your entire life you understand
that somebody's paying for you
don't go and listen to smart people tell
you stuff you don't have to go on the
web and read they sit there and tell you
like what do you do I went to sleep like
come on right you get to the point or
you or you I can't wait to get on and
meet my boyfriend it's always about
something else the reason is because
you're not okay and if you're not okay
you can't enjoy what's happening to you
you have to be looking for the thing
that will be okay that will make you be
okay so we have the groundwork down the
problem here is that you're not okay
inside if you were okay inside your life
would be totally different wouldn't it
you understand that like relationships
you're wrong if you think a relationship
is supposed to make you feel loved
is supposed to make you feel needed and
whole and important that's wrong that's
wrong you're supposed to feel love to
start with that's natural love is part
of your being you're supposed to feel
whole and complete within yourself right
tremendous openness and power right now
go out and share it with another person
that's a relationship don't need and
then get upset because they didn't give
it to you never say that there's no way
it's my view I've done it for 45 years
right there's no way that if you can't
fix what's wrong with you inside there's
someone else is going to do it
they don't even know you they got their
own problems I was CEO of a public
corporation went through all kinds of
stuff
I see no difference between
being in the temple Universe whatever it
is and I found it kind of people started
coming out there so it happened that's
how my whole life is right I never
decided to do anything I just followed
the energy like I was saying I'm there
doing Services you know meditating
whoever it is and different events
unfold the one particular one that I
tell in the surrender experiment is
a sheriff came out to the land and I was
barefoot of hippie you know walking
around my land and he walked up to the
temple building that we built which I
was a little concerned you know has
Krishna and and Jewish things it has all
the different religions represented and
he's all dressed up in his officer
uniform and pulls his big car up there
and I'm walking around barefoot no shirt
on and he says uh you in charge here
yeah I guess I am you know he says
did you build this building I said yes
he said would you build an addition on
my house
I swear to God that's exactly what
happened all right and because I was
surrendering to life
nothing inside of me wanted to build
clothes in the garage or this Sheriff
all right it's like I'm not even a
builder I built a couple of buildings on
my own land you know rough sawn Timber
Etc and I said yes and that founded my
first company built with love and they
ended up building custom houses and this
and that and then I got into computers
and the next thing I knew people were
asking me to write computer programs and
I just talked I didn't know it was a
course in my life I just started writing
as I found it interesting like you find
stuff interesting and bought a Terrace
80 model one when Radio Shack first came
out with a little tiny computers all
right and wrote an accounting program to
run built with love and then people
wanted to buy the program
that's literally how this company
started and so I said okay I guess so I
didn't start surrendering and then I got
to write this and write that and do this
and eventually somebody asked me to
write a medical billing system and I had
I didn't even go to the doctor in those
days and I'd never seen an insurance
form in my life all right and I took it
and I did it I did it and it became this
major company you know with 2300
employees and public and the whole ball
game and so I just had to do it I just
did it well while I was doing it I
didn't change I didn't say now this is
what I'm doing now this is a wonderful
opportunity to let go of me like you can
bet you know for sure you can bet that
being in that environment I mean
literally I'm on earning calls with Wall
Street like give me a break all right I
can't relate to any of it but I'm doing
my best I'm serving and working hard
doing everything as an act of letting go
of myself and serving the universe I
never wasn't about business it wasn't
about this the other thing but you do
that you try as hard as you can and just
try to serve everybody and you can do
pretty well when I was you know 22 23
years old
I realized that that voice was running
my life
and that's what you're saying if it
wasn't comfortable I left
if it you know whatever it was it was
determining what I said it was
determined how I acted it was
determining everything about my life and
yet I didn't know a thing about that
voice why was it saying what it was
saying why why is it like one person and
not another because when you like
somebody your voice says I like her so
where did that come from right and if
all of a sudden it said no I don't think
so I don't think then you don't it's
like telling you and your emotions go
along with it and it's this whole
psychological system that's going on
inside so I made the decision not and
I'm not saying people should right but
it's nice to share that I wasn't going
to live my life without understanding
what was going on because it didn't make
sense okay and it already caused a lot
of trouble in my life just like it does
everybody else's all right it's like oh
your relations is so hard and everything
else and changing jobs it just decides I
don't like my boss I don't like the boss
anymore it's telling you that why didn't
it just say I like the boss like no one
actually pays attention to how much
control it has over your life or why
it's saying what it's saying so what I
did was to say I'm going to take a
little sabbatical hiatus
about a year or so I meant to put aside
and devote my life to watching that
voice and figure out why it says what it
says what is my relationship to it and I
in essence dropped out I don't like
teaching that now because people
shouldn't drop out I mean not they
shouldn't but they don't need to and I'm
not teaching them to right but I did I
was it was a I think you know I was in a
doctoral program for economics the
university and last year ready to get my
doctorate and I stepped aside and went
into Solitude relative Solitude and I
watched very very carefully and what I
saw made me more uncomfortable than what
you were talking about all right like
watching it when it was in his glory
because you know you pull yourself aside
it's going to say a lot of stuff made me
realize I don't listen to that thing
that thing's crazy it just changed his
mind all the time it says this it says
that like the reason people drink and do
drugs is because that thing's driving
them crazy do you understand that are
you trying to get away from that in
inner mess that's going on inside so
basically over the course of many years
I started an experiment which was what
would happen if I didn't listen to that
what does that mean it tells you what to
do and so on well what if I listen to
Life instead and that's very subtle what
if the events unfolding in front of me
were more important than whether I like
them or not
and I was willing to listen if I'm
meeting this person perhaps it has some
meaning the fact that I'm not
comfortable with them maybe has no
meaning right and I started practicing
letting go of myself instead of letting
go of what it told me to and and
sometimes it told me to do something
sometimes I wouldn't do it what I got
was as follows
just because it told me to do it is not
going to be the reason I do it just
because it told me not to do it isn't or
that it doesn't like it it's not going
to be the reason I don't do it that
doesn't mean that I'm doing or not doing
I will let life the unfolding of Life
the circumstances that unfold in front
of me talk to me instead of that thing
talking to me so that that's the basics
of what I call surrender you're not
surrendering to life you're not
surrendering to people you're not saying
yes to everything you're just basically
saying my head doesn't know what it's
talking about it's just a bunch of noise
he's making a little allergies it's just
a bunch of noise and I'm better off not
listening to that personal noise doesn't
mean intellectually if I'm solving a
math problem or I'm trying to decide you
know create air conditioning or building
I built for a while reading plans and so
on the mind's wonderful for that I'm
talking about the personal mind I like
this I don't like that I believe in this
I don't believe in that I want this to
happen oh my God I hope it doesn't rain
tomorrow because I'll die if it rains
that kind of junk just the personal
noise that instead of honoring and
respecting life is judging it and trying
to tell me how to make life be my way
instead of my respecting that life took
13.8 billion years to get here that's
that's a big stick I have right that
every moment in front of me took every
single thing to happen exactly like it
did for 13.8 billion years for that
thing to be in front of me do you
understand that because if you're if
you're a great great great grandmother
didn't meet your great great great
grandfather you're not here
okay you're trying to make your Neurosis
or your anxiety relax no anxiety doesn't
know how to relax anxiety is anxious
you're saying that this is nature right
it's all jumpy and stuff like that right
but you who's noticing it you has the
hands in there you can relax you can sit
there and say okay fine just relax and
lean away from the noise just go to that
place okay that's not it's like a Zone
like what I'm saying athletes talk about
being in the zone right there's a Zone
inside if you relax behind that noise
there's a peace back there there's a
there's a quiet doesn't be a big
spiritual experience but it's a heck of
a lot nicer to hang out with anxiety
yeah it's the Observer that's what it
feels like you're the Observer and you
relax and if you do that over time not
immediately but over time you will find
that that which was making you anxious
the Neurosis downstairs oh my God my
boss is going man I told him I'd be
there I'm going to be late you can just
late anyways sorry it's not going to
change a thing you look at that and you
realize I'm okay I'm okay it doesn't do
any good to show up neurotic okay so you
let go and as you let go you'll notice
amazing thing that energy that was all
weird because you didn't touch it it
changed it was able to come up all right
or you start using affirmation right you
sit there and say oh come on this is
probably a an older person like my
grandmother my grandmother I do yes yes
that's right they get to drive and I
should not be talking at them or
bothering them or even sending them bad
vibes maybe they should not be driving
any faster well and the point is it's
the latter part of their life and at
least they get to go some places or
something and it means a lot more to
them than this Neurosis means to be and
you feel like you're giving something
instead of demanding and taking you can
change yourself it's not about
suppressing it's not about denying it's
about raising you raise yourself pausing
almost feels like it generates
compassion a little bit what you'll find
out is you back there are the most
beautiful thing in the whole universe
you are filled with love you're filled
with compassion you're full of
inspiration you're filled with like well
shock the energy the spirit energy quote
whatever you want filled with it all the
time but you're busy looking down at
this garbage and so you learn to raise
yourself the other example that I like
to use because I'm very much into
being Broad and seeing the whole
universe instead of just your little
tiny world right is let's say it's hot
out nowadays you have global warming
we're hot okay it's very hot out you're
standing there and you have to go from
one place to another and you're actually
outside with no air conditioning isn't
that terrible and as you're walking
you're complaining oh my God it's so
freaking hot and I'm sweating I don't
want to sweat I don't like this sort of
thing and I always have to be so hot
what's wrong with these people blah blah
okay well that doesn't help anything it
doesn't make it cooler it doesn't do a
single thing it's the same thing like
the car but what if you sat there I know
I trained Mickey this I trained Michael
this way all right as I sit there and I
look and I say how did it get hot be
quiet how did it get hot what do you
mean why is it hot
well because there's a son out there you
mean there's a star 93 billion miles
away and you're it's hot it's so hot
that you feel it's heat here I'm in
Gainesville Florida Miami is about 300
miles away I asked them how big would a
fire have to be in Miami for you to
steal it in Gainesville if the whole
town caught fire you would not even know
what happened that thing's 93 million
you hear that it's 93 million miles away
and you can feel the star shine okay you
can feel is that means
yeah I could feel a star the stars are
neat things right and you start working
with yourself that way and it works you
raise yourself
the mind is very strong
and one of the things the Mind does is
develop methodologies or ways of
thinking that let it interact with life
and not get hurt and be more comfortable
and it's the ego when we develop a
self-concept and we change it through
our lives but in general there's a
self-concept sitting under there saying
I was the one that did this and I was
the one that went to the school and I'm
the one that went there and the one that
my father left or stayed or whatever the
hell it is excuse me and basically uh
all of this unfolds and you end up
developing patterns of thinking based
upon the experiences you've had all
right and what I'm saying at least
certainly in my experience is that's not
what makes you wake up that's what keeps
you from waking up
all right the fact that you're
identifying with these past experiences
and saying that's who I am well it's not
who you are you are watching your ego
you see it get upset you see it fix
things you see it have Concepts and
Views and Etc et cetera and even you're
obviously very intelligent you can use
your intellect to support the ego to
support that and and so on right and I'm
sure yes you're a very special person
you're an intelligent person and
therefore that becomes part of your
self-concept okay and then you say a
religious person part of your
self-concept all of these things are
ways you think of yourself and there's
nothing at all wrong with that it's
wonderful you've been successful you're
happy you're doing well all right I'm
not happy I'm not doing well I just said
that
and also like weeping openly at this
moment okay but listen to me right that
identification with your personal self
which is just your mind's thoughts are
what keep you from waking up we call
them mindset is the conditioning of the
mind that makes it so the things turn
you on and turn you off and that's where
you get your list of what you want and
what you don't want it is not true that
you want those things
what you want is something that will
open you so that you can feel the joy
that is natural when you're open and you
don't want the things to close you so
that you get blocked off from any joy
and you get this sense of depression so
you have a choice even right at that
point and we haven't even gone deep yet
you have a choice do you want to spend
your life
deciding what you want and what you
don't want and then chasing it outside
or do you want to sit there and work
inside to realize all I really want is
the joy and the love and if I stay open
I can have those I don't need outside
conditions to keep me open so I make it
I make a very important point because in
spirituality it gets mixed up
spirituality is not about renunciation
there's no renunciation renunciation
says I've decided what it is that will
make me happy and I'm not going to do it
well that sounds rather absurd all right
spirituality says it was stupid of me to
decide what will make me happy instead
of being happy with life instead of
being grateful and turned on by all of
the amazing things that are happening in
front of me and all the past experiences
I got to have why don't I just enjoy all
that and then come into life filled with
love filled with joy and give the hold
of my being to the moments that are
unfolding in front of me that's that's
what spirituality says so it's not about
renunciation it's not about things are
wrong and things are right
it's about understanding that you did
this you did this with your mind you set
up conditions in which your mind would
open and then your heart opens and
conditions in which your mind will close
and your heart closes so spirituality is
very positive you'll say spirituality is
not logical and rational it is so it's
saying to you why are you doing that if
you want to have a beautiful life spin
around a planet in the middle of
nowheres why don't you just open it's
your heart it's your mind it doesn't
need conditions to open it's just you
don't know how to do it as you become
used to programs uh habitual that you
had a past experience as by the way this
is where it comes from how did you
decide how did your mind decide what it
is you want and what you don't want you
did not make those decisions they were
programmed into you by your past
experiences all of them
so you had a past experience where
something was nice with a certain person
they looked a certain way they had a
certain name they drove a certain kind
of car whatever it is and you really was
really was high for you it was beautiful
years and years ago now one of those
things shows up you meet somebody with
that name as shallow as that sounds
don't kid yourself you meet someone with
the name of your ex you close down even
though it's not the same person you meet
someone with the name of who you had
your first date with in high school that
it was a wonderful relationship and you
open up and likewise when you see a car
they had a nice experience in it turned
you on so you are programmed by your
past experiences such that if they were
good experiences they tend to open you
when something reminds you of them when
they were negative experience they tend
to close you and that is where you get
your list of what you want that's why
all of our lists are different
everyone's listening is totally
different someone tells you this is the
same as yours they're manipulating you
because everyone has had different
experiences and based upon those
experiences it left these impressed
questions on your mind and you came up
with this list of what I want so when
you make the list of what you want what
you don't want you're really making a
list of your past that's how you came up
with those things even colors that you
like anything
there are Impressions Skinner the
psychologist said man is the sum of his
learned experiences it's not true it's
true that your mind and your heart are
the your personal heart are the some of
your learned experiences but you are in
there noticing this so I make a big
distinction with BF right that you are
in there and you are noticing that your
mind is a some of your learned
experiences and it is that's what
psychology meets spirituality psychology
is right all of the psyche your thoughts
your patterns your likes your dislikes
your problems and neuroses Etc are the
some of your learned experiences but you
are in there you're the Consciousness
the awareness of being who notices that
what I'm saying is true
so basically you come to the point where
you have to decide do I want to continue
letting my past leave Impressions on my
mind and my heart such that only certain
things will open and close me and then I
will spend my life chasing after
manipulating controlling conniving
whatever you want
the world around me so that sometimes it
unfolds the way I want or do you want to
sit there and understand that you're the
one who's making these decisions it's
your mind who setting up the conditions
why don't you just not do that you can
start with positive thinking that's one
level that at least you should be doing
that right you sit there and say we'll
make it through this and even if I don't
whatever it is I will be a better person
because of this if you're in into God
running everything if that's your state
God knows what he's doing there are so
many different things that you can do
with positive thinking to create a nicer
environment inside in my opinion you
have an obligation to do that both for
yourself for the health of your body for
people around you you just lift yourself
up the heater says one should raise the
selfless self not trample down the self
this is a time to be doing that work so
you can't say I can't do that you can
you can make your mind say things you're
going to be used to say every time
there's a negative thought place it with
a positive one it's a good time to
practice that so it's it's wowing for
itself oh my God this is terrible I'll
be fine this is okay God knows what he's
doing or you know this is just reality
it's just reality he accepted either way
and then the next level is you sit there
and if you do Mantra and mantras have to
be an Eastern you know Sanskrit Mantra
but it just gets something going behind
that you're hanging on to it a deeper
part of your mind I'll be okay this is
okay I'll use it whatever it is right
then what will happen is when the lower
cell starts these situations happen you
just settle back into it so you have a
choice which mind you want to listen to
the lower mind which we know what it's
like or you've built something beautiful
inside and then ultimately the highest
state is you relax every single time
something hits your stuff you relax you
relax relax and let go relaxing itself
is Letting Go people sometimes I say
well I relax how do I let go the very
fact that you chose to relax relax your
shoulders lectures tummy Etc and and
just relax inside you that is Letting Go
you're not getting all involved in
what's going on so that's the highest
state is you just keep letting go and
the worse it is the better is keep
letting go you just to commit yourself
I'm going to use this right then you of
course put aside some time in the
morning and evening to remind yourself
that this is what I'm doing why don't we
deal with it exactly the same insides as
we deal with it outside and just sit
there and say yes there are experience
in life that are not pleasant good I'd
like to learn from them doesn't mean I
want to have them I'm not praying for
them right but if they happen to present
themselves in front of me this is my
opportunity to become a greater being to
be able to handle the reality of life
there
and so that's also the thorn you talk
about right that you can carry you let
it go let things go yeah instead of
compensating for them and learning how
to be okay that it's there it's only
there because inside
there are no Thorns there's no physical
being it's a theoric inside it's
completely open okay how hard is your
future change your mind
they're wrong right okay there's nothing
in there it's it's just it's totally
empty right it's just loose right it's
looser than the clouds so why not make
it nice in there so if something comes
in and it's disturbing yeah I always
tell people if you went through a
traumatic terrible experience when you
were young I wish I could go down there
and beat the people up and go back in
time and protect you oh I would love to
do that but I can't I can't and you
can't either nor can anybody else right
so I will blame the person who
mistreated you or did this thing to you
when you were five years old your
innocent child right for causing the
truck that problem then but they stopped
they went away they moved they died you
know rest I don't care it's whatever
it's over right but you didn't let it be
over for the next 30 Years you did it I
have to blame you for those 30 years I
can't blame them they're not there
I can't blame the experience is not even
happening how dare you blame the
experience that happened 25 years ago
you are the one who chose to keep that
inside of you and let it destroy your
life I always teach this
first let go then if it's still there
deal with it you're going to find out
that 95 of the time once you relax and
let go there's nothing left to deal with
If somebody walks up you say hey Sally
how are you doing she doesn't turn
around and say hello and she's your
friend okay no there's there's an
experience it's not comfortable what's
wrong why shouldn't you know blah blah
did she not hear me all that stuff goes
on right relax through it relax through
it okay okay fine that's what happened
now what are you gonna do about it
nothing she's not there anymore there's
nothing to do right and you're crazy
it's the next time you see something why
didn't you say that
you won't do that because you handled it
there's no reason to say anything what a
nice person you are maybe she didn't
hear you maybe she's in a bad mood who
cares
right so if you are willing to let go
you're going to find out the vast
majority of the time there is nothing to
do about it except let go if someone
were to listen to this conversation from
the seat of awareness what what would
that be like how would they do that
that's jumping ahead a whole lot but
let's start there okay
you are aware
people don't pay attention to the fact
that they're aware but obviously they're
aware you see through your eyes you hear
through your ears and you you feel touch
and so on
who does that what does that your eyes
don't see you see through your eyes your
skin passes messages back to you your
ears take up Sound Vibrations send them
back to you who is that in there and
where in there it's not really
everywhere there's a place inside of
yourself from which you listen that's
why some meditation techniques are very
beautiful they tell you to just listen
listen to quiet listen to whatever
sounds there pay attention listen then
you really realize you're in there
trying to listen
so basically but but you're asking a
deep question the Deep answer is you are
inside and if you meditate and you pay
attention and work with witness
Consciousness you're going to find out
that there is a place in there where you
are and that the sites that are coming
in are outside of you even inside your
thoughts are outside of you you'll feel
that they're at a distance from you
because you're sitting in a center of
Consciousness and then you're projecting
your Consciousness onto objects of
Consciousness it is always highest thing
you can do
harmonize with the moment that's
unfolding in front of you that goes for
business goes for relationships goes for
sports it goes for children so many
people make it so anxious to bring up a
child oh my God what do I need to do oh
it's almost a natural thing in the world
be present in the moment with each stage
the child is going through and bring
your best game
but for you but I wanted to be a lawyer
I was never a noun you dare do that you
come into the moment with the child and
you try to hear what they're saying you
tried to see what they're going through
and you tried to see how you can raise
that moment to the best of your ability
that's all you can do that's the highest
thing you can do and it will end up with
the highest results that could possibly
happen you need to worry about it you
need to think about it you don't need to
feel guilty you don't need to feel shame
nothing you're just in the current
moment you bring your best game what's
your best game it starts with honoring
and respecting the moment that's in
front of you period not just accepting
that's not even enough loving gratitude
I could be experiencing nothing
that's what he said to me the other day
that remember and I said this how much
of the universe is blank empty space
99.99999 do you understand that because
all there is out there is blank empty
space
you do know that don't you you know I
think our nearest star Alpha Proxima
whatever it is this is what was it 4.5
light years away the nearest star
nothing in between 4.5 light years away
now far away that is if I caught a light
beam and held it above the Earth if I
let it go for one second
it's just circumnavigated the Earth
eight times
oh it's a little faster do that every
single second for 4.5 years and you'll
get to the next star
the next galaxy is 2.4 million light
years away so I mean there's nothing but
empty space everywhere and you get to
have this in front of you
that's just interesting color shapes
things so what I taught the person
repeated it to me last night is instead
of comparing what is going on in front
of you against what you want what you
made up based on your past compare it
against nothing
feel gratitude I am grateful that I get
to have this experience and be that way
with every single moment in your life
that's the highest life you can live in
it that's the highest life you can live
on and you'll stop storing stuff inside
of you because you'll stop saying I
don't want this
it's all exciting it's all challenging
I'm willing to go through anything it's
just a challenging experience it's a fun
thing and you'll become empty inside and
that becomes your spiritual growth also
as you start to embrace the moments in
front of you with the whole of your
being you become empty you become pure
and all this Energy starts to well up
inside of you for our next foray
and to how to bring spirituality into
the workplace and make the workplace
spiritual
this is something we ran into I was in
program design for the medical industry
and so sometimes we'd have projects
given to us where they wouldn't be
defined at all they'd just be oh I know
how to keep my medical records in the
computer it could mean a million
different things it was early in the
game when no one was computerized
medical records
or appointment scheduling what does it
mean what are the criteria there were no
specifications
so there are times when you are given a
project that you literally don't know
what to do it's just that simple it's
not that you're blocked is that you
haven't had the experience there isn't
someone to turn to that has had the
experience
so you bring a team together and no one
in that team knows what to do
so that brings up a really interesting
teaching of how to work spiritually and
how the benefits of all the Deep Eastern
teachings can come into the workplace
what we used to do in a situation like
that is they bring my team together six
or seven people would sit around all
very very high level developers and the
first criteria that I would work with is
are you all willing to admit you don't
have an answer you don't know
and I'm their boss they don't like
saying that but you have to start with
reality otherwise somebody's walking
into that room thinking they're supposed
to have an answer they don't but they
made something up that is noise that
just creates tremendous trouble in the
workplace in a meeting in this creative
environment all right that somebody
thinks they know but what they really
know is I want to know and I want to
impress everybody and I'm afraid of not
knowing so it's just ego garbage and so
you don't want to bring that into the
meeting so what do you do how do you
start everybody's sitting there
admitting I don't know so what I learned
to do and what I taught them I called it
the yin yang method of design of solving
problems that you don't have the answers
to
you don't know how to start so let's
start somewhere you start with asking
the question well what's the minimum
that I could do it's not the right
answer we're not going to do it nobody's
justifying it but what is the minimum
that we could do and claim that it
satisfied this project that we've been
given and you talk about it don't design
it don't get down to detail because
we're not going to stay there you just
get a feeling of what's right about the
minimum what's wrong about the minimum
and all of a sudden you know about this
you know why that's not enough you can
get passionate about it you know why it
won't solve this problem or that problem
or satisfy one of your clients right and
you know why you have to release that we
can't go lower than that right because
it doesn't do anything and all of a
sudden you're having a fruitful engaged
beautiful discussion where a minute ago
everybody was saying I don't know
anything and all of a sudden you're like
you do know something you do know what
the minimum looks like so you start with
that but you don't design it you don't
get down to oh what will we do what will
look like no no no just talk about what
the pros and cons of this being the
minimum find the minimum find the lower
Edge then immediately once you put that
to rest for a moment don't let anybody
Buy in don't say oh I think that's right
I'm not interested it's not about what
you like like it or don't like it it's
about admitting this is the least we
could do and here's the pros and cons of
that then go to the expansive what's the
most you could do what's the most you
could do there is the most you could do
you know it could take you three years
to do it but given that situation that
you're talking about just let your mind
go what is the most that you could do
you know going beyond that would be
ridiculous there'd be no way you'd need
to there'd be no way you'd want to what
is the outer edge of what this project
could look like all right if you're
really just expanded it into what's the
most it could mean the main obstacle is
the unwillingness to experience what it
feels like to go through withdrawal what
is the obstacle for a person getting off
of hard drugs or getting off of alcohol
they could be very committed they said I
want to do it right but there is that
tendency that you have habits you have
you have Tendencies and to let these go
require a certain amount of commitment
and a certain amount of strength a
center of will that I really am
committed to this and then you go
through this process of withdrawal this
process of purification it isn't
comfortable but you have to want the
result more than you're afraid of the
discomfort so I always tell people it's
not about whether you like something or
not it's a question where you can handle
it don't ask yourself do I like this or
not ask yourself can I handle this in
the rhetorical question because you
better be able to because the
alternative to be able to handle
something is you can't handle it and I
don't want to be around nor do you right
so you just that we talk about that
Center of will that Center of volition
you sit in there and realize I got junk
inside of me I've developed patterns
that are not healthy just like drugs I
mean I'm not saying they're doing drugs
right but it's it's like a drug it's
like alcohol you have these patterns of
reactions that are just got formed
inside of you when you weren't paying
attention and now you need to let them
go so the obstacle is your unwillingness
to go through what it takes to Let It Go
the moment you decide I want out I want
to let this go and there's two reason to
let it go one is the non-negative
because it sure cause you a lot of
trouble all that noise in there and the
other is the positive both are fine I
want to let it go because I want to have
a reasonable life I want to let it go
because I want to have one life to live
I want to experience the highest I can
possibly experience I want to explore
the depth of my being I want to know
what I meant when he said my father and
I are one I want to know where Buddha
went with Nirvana whatever level you
feel the positive right and both of
those The Inspirations are non-negative
and the inspiration of the positive
should give you the drive the the
inspiration the intention that you need
in order to say I'm Letting Go I'm
letting go because the alternative is
absurd the alternative is to give my
life to the lowest part of my being
there are so many situations in our
everyday experiences of work that are
just excellent opportunities for growth
so for example you find yourself in a
meeting and there's a group of people
and they're sharing ideas and their
views the first thing I want to talk
about is if you watch what you're going
to realize is you're not really
listening
you're doing one of two things and this
goes even not just for meetings just
even in conversations when you're just
sit there talking to somebody
either when they're talking and you're
supposedly listening what you're
actually listening to is your own view
of what they're saying you're listening
to the voice inside your head say well I
never did anything like that I wonder
why yeah I wouldn't want that to happen
to me either and no no I wouldn't say it
the way you said it I would but and
you're in there talking the voice inside
your head is talking and you're actually
paying as much if not more attention to
your opinion view judgment whatever it
is extensions add-ons and subtractions
to what's being said then you are paying
attention to the words coming out of the
person's mouth and that's if you're
actually listening what happens very
often in a meeting and I see it all the
time with people all right is they're
not even listening to anybody saying
they're thinking about what they're
going to say when it's their turn that's
all that's going on inside their head is
they're just thinking about how do I
formulate that's unbelievable I
shouldn't even have to talk on that if
you're doing that you don't belong in
the meeting because the purpose of the
meeting is we're all different we're all
different we all have different stuff
inside of our heads because we've all
had different experiences in life we've
all had different experiences and we've
process them different ways therefore
the data that we have for the foundation
of our thoughts is completely different
than everybody else in that room even if
you worked together for 20 years still
your background your upbringing what
happened outside of work all of these
things formulate the way you think so
when you walk into a room with a meeting
you understand that what you have is a
whole bunch of data sets and every one
of those data sets is correct there's
not one of them that's more correct than
the other if I look out a window
everybody looks out the window but looks
at different angles there's nobody who's
seeing it right they're just seeing
what's out there is bigger than any one
thing you can see so no person has gone
through life experiencing what's there
all the experience of what was in front
of them from moment to moment so
therefore everybody is right everybody
has a different experience of life
therefore everybody has something to
contribute
if criticism creates reaction inside
which of course it does like you said in
most people then are you willingness
used to say use it to go to God I always
love that I keep that with me are you
willing to say hey I bothered meditating
you told me all these intense practices
you did is fasting this all you've read
all stuff I used to do right here it is
here's a moment where the very thing
that is keeping you from the ascent has
shown its face to you are you willing to
use that for your spiritual growth and
that has to be deep deep inside and the
answer is yes of course I am okay then
you need to bring these energies up what
happened there when you got hot in the
energy got hot and the breath went
faster the snippy comments is that
basically it hit a blockage it hit a
blockage expanded out and so basically
what your willingness to do is to say I
can stay centered in the midst of that
blockage and I can relax so the key is
relaxing you're right we didn't talk
about that because Letting Go those are
just words the key is can I relax in the
face of the reaction and when people
come to me and say well the anger will
relax well of course not anger doesn't
know how to relax defensiveness doesn't
know how to relax but you who's
experiencing I love you obviously were
talking to me from a place of witness
Consciousness because you described to
me what it felt like to have that
reaction that meant you were in there
noticing it you who notices it wants to
do something about it to make it stop
that's why you have these snippy
comments that's why you attack or
whatever run away whatever it is right
fight or flight right no what you need
to do about it is relax if you're
relaxed instead you gave us some space
to release so you're absolutely right it
is not breathe and let go that doesn't
mean anything breathe means something
but let go those are just words they
don't mean a single thing what it means
is catch your breath for a moment make a
commitment I want to use this to go to
God I want to use this for my spiritual
growth I want to use this to liberate
myself from myself all right there now
you have your intention now I'm asking
you to relax it's not easy you'll see
the energy tries to pull you into it
right that's what you're trying to do
right if I have to pull you in to get
you to feed the reaction instead you
relax and just the very Act of relaxing
leaves some space for a little little
bit of it to pass through the more you
relax the more you lean away from the
energy that's making all the noise the
more space you leave and that's a very
very deep spiritual practice to relax
and release I call it r r to relax and
release everything all the time first
let go that's what I mean by let go
relax and release now deal with the
situation don't deal with your reaction
instead of looking at the decision
you're trying to make ask yourself what
are you trying to get from this decision
what's your motive what you're going to
find out is every single time it is
either I'm trying to make a decision
that will make me feel better make me
happier in the future let me achieve a
better State inside myself or a more
content more excited more enthused you
know feel higher et cetera or I'm trying
to make a decision that will save me
from having to experience something that
I don't want to experience which way can
I choose this so it's a path of least
resistance so you find that the motive
behind your decision as opposed to
getting all involved in the decision you
step back and say what am I trying to
achieve and you're going to see that
it's either a desire or a fear you're
trying to achieve a desire by moving to
New York or moving to California which
won't work for me right you're trying to
make your mind be psychic to figure out
which one will make you happier versus
I'm trying to avoid a situation that I
don't want and then you take a look at
that and you realize what I'm really
trying to decide is how to be happy
inside how to be in a better State
inside myself well why don't I say that
honestly it's not really about this
decision it's about how can I find a
more beautiful state inside myself and
that's where it leads to yoga that's
where it leaves everything leads to
spirituality because it says the state
you're looking for is inside yourself
what are the words that got to do with
where you live or what your job is or
who you marry it's got to do with how
you're doing inside yourself why don't
you work on that a little bit instead of
trying to put the burden on your mind of
thinking that some decision you're going
to make down the road is going to decide
the quality of your life because the
truth of the matter is the state of your
being is going to determine the quality
of your life if you're whole if you're
complete if you're enthused if you're
filled with love it doesn't matter which
place you live in you're gonna be
wonderful and if you're disturbed inside
it's not California New York that's
going to make the difference it does for
a short period of time because it's new
and therefore you're more open to it so
you step back behind the decision and
you look to see where you're coming from
and at some point if you come deep
enough at looking at how you'll realize
I have put a burden on my mind of saying
this is going to determine the quality
of my life and it's not true you can
determine the quality of your life to at
least come back to that Center that deep
Center inside that undercuts all this
then you're going to find out that you
don't put the pressure on yourself with
that decision and often it will unfold
naturally doesn't mean you don't make a
decision not indecision but you'll find
that if you make get rid of the noise
inside of you you'll be able to see more
clearly what is actually happening and
what is maybe a better way to serve a
better way to balance the energies as
opposed to how can I make myself happy
with this decision or how can I avoid my
fears with this decision the highest
life you can live is that every moment
that passed in front of you is better
off because it did
every moment because it passed in front
of you you interacted with a way that
when it went on its way it was higher
than before it passed before you
that's Saint francis's prayer isn't it
make me an instrument of thy peace where
there's sickness when we bring health or
there's sadness let me bring joy not let
me take from the moment when you're when
you're not okay inside you're taking you
need you're taking when you're okay
inside you're giving to the moment
you're raising the moment not according
to what you think should be happening in
accordance to what you're hearing the
moment bring to you it talks to you
that's not mystical if there are storm
clouds up ahead and you see sheets of
rain in a distance life is telling you
it is probably going to rain where you
are
that's literally Chrysler LED those of
us does he let them see let those over
ears to hear Let Them hear in other
words come on get out of your head
and pay attention to what's going on in
front of you that's all you need to do
that's all you need to do it will tell
you everything you need it'll give you
an idea where it's going give you an
idea where it's coming from give an idea
what it needs on this journey and you
become a servant you become a servant of
the moment that's in front of you and
then you let it go
Let It Go how many of you have
conversations with somebody and then
when the conversation is over you walk
away the conversation's not over inside
your head oh I shouldn't have said oh
I've only had said this oh my God oh my
God you're probably saying I'm so stupid
I should call him no don't call them
you're really stupid
what is that you're missing the next
moment because you're being neurotic
about the last one so you can't possibly
be doing the best you can do you
understand that because there's
literally a moment unfolding in front of
you while you're doing that you're
obviously missing that moment aren't you
because you're caught in the last one
you should have the ability to have a
conversation be present in the
conversation absolutely do the best that
you can in that conversation to raise it
and if it's business you can raise it
for you know to do the best in business
if it's relation we raise it a best for
love nobody's saying you're not
interacting with it in harmony with its
purpose but basically when it's over I'm
telling it's over
all that stuff you do of causing
yourself a hard time and building all
that junk inside that's not helping
doesn't help why or she makes it more
neurotic
so basically you let go then you come
present the next moment and you just
live in the harmony of the moment you
give yourself to it that is what loud
Sue meant by the Dao and he ever studied
the Dao he called it the way
the way the way of life the way of that
is all of Zen that is all of everything
it's all the martial arts it's all the
sports why do you think they teach
football players and other people to
meditate is because this state of
openness the state of harmony with
what's going on will give you that edge
instead of being caught in your mind
so life is beautiful
no one will tell you that all of Life is
Beautiful birth is Beautiful Death is
beautiful everything's beautiful
except that you make it not be beautiful
because you've made up how you want it
to be your house is beautiful you're the
one who makes it not beautiful because
you think it's not big enough because
you wish the color would change because
you know you've got The Neighbor Next
Door got a nicer one Everything Is
Beautiful
if you interact with it with a sense of
respect with a sense of Honor with a
sense of being and what is amazing that
if you do that I don't know how to talk
about the purpose of my second book The
certain experiment was that somehow just
by doing that what unfolds is way higher
than anything you could ever do all you
can be responsible for is yourself your
starting position is right you have to
evolve with the different situations
that are presented to you and my
experiences if you do that
the rest will happen the people around
you will be raised naturally understand
that like if you bring anger into a
situation imagine a household or always
fighting if all of a sudden somebody's
not and somebody's bringing
understanding and love that's all they
have to do it will change things
right but you you can't sit there and
say I won't change until everybody else
does you know it's not going to protect
myself that doesn't work
right so that you're asking you like
there's no surprise you I said big
things all right it's like can it be
better of course it could be better but
it requires that everybody work on
themselves
because while they're not working on
themselves they're working on everybody
else they're just trying to manipulate
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bruce Lipton motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there one of the things
that really upset me for a long time was
the fact that I had great ideas and
intentions and I wanted to manifest them
and I thought this is how it's going to
manifest and so I had all these visions
of how things were going to unfold and
then I'd start a process and I wouldn't
unfold